hello everyone it's me Harrigan with my
chair talking about means you had a herd
of those what's the next meme feelings
shaggy memes meme Rubio give you shaggy
memes oh boy
can't wait for those to die shaggy is
apparently so strong how did he get so
strong you might ask
I've seen this raw string only once
before god damn may I say it isn't just
looks trunk
he looks a hunka dog let's have a look
at his real power his raw strength how
did he acquire this this can go two ways
Punk one you walk away - I walk on your
face like this song is awesome it's so
aggressive like that's the spirit let's
do it Wow shaggy was born and bred by
Isis and that's where he got his power
some say he's actually PD PI and that's
how he lost all his power like me you
made me use 10% of my power
[Music]
oh dear universe please never let this
end okay so this is the actor of the
shaggy shaggy next to Jesus Christ only
one person in history has ever been as
strong as shaggy
and it's geez
[Music]
now Scooby dill your mom eats cat poop
damn all of the dogs we brought in to
play Scooby were instantly vaporized
upon entering Shaggy's parlor radius we
had no choice but to use CGI oh damn I
didn't know that
fun fact fun fact fun fact Scooby got
waves everyone comment in the chat right
now on every single video you have ever
seen Scooby got waves okay you think
that oh yeah yes [ __ ] was annoying yeah
well you ain't heard about Scooby got
waves and Scooby got waves it's good we
got waves still we have wait I'll be
funny for like half a minute
what I'm the king with Scooby Doo all
along what who would win shaggy and 100%
power or I can balance my body on my
boner and spend like a fairy blade no
one can defeat me dad like I'm secretly
running the Akatsuki this whole time man
damn Sugoi desu nee okay banners for
shaggy don't do it
[Music]
we should measure shed its power in
Shagga watts sent and sends a both
allows Shaggy to possess infinite power
and allow vessels to absorb his power I
know what you guys are talking about at
this point
Mortal Kombat eleven comes firms a fan
favorite hero is now officially a
villain shaggy no shaggy for mortal
combat please is it just me or am I the
only one that prefers the old-school
shaggy memes I prefer the old check it
was so much better like this one for
example when you're about to nut and
they tell you to please leave the
funeral but that's a good shaggy mean
that's an actually excellent shaggy me I
can relate to it at least
when Scoob will explain it butter off
your jinkies and you keep joking like
that is totally me that is totally me
let me punch you to sketch about it so I
can relate to it don't say you watch
scooby-doo for the plot damn Ron asleep
run run Marie will rock right right
right
January means have I've really been
something special I will say that at
least for some reason the shaggy meme
out of all means this is one of those
two everyone gets behind no I get it
shaggy nice a high power lever everyone
knows that right
[Music]
I'm making [ __ ] cheese that's how you
know you don't mess with shaggy now
unfortunately like old memes that goes
mainstream they come crashing down
faster than a an airplane that is
crashing down polygon already cover this
powerful shaggy and it's investigation
if getting a mean review wasn't a sure
way to kill the me and I don't know what
cook polygon this a meme that seemingly
spawned from nowhere has a carefully
built history so we started with these
behind the scenes fanfiction I don't
know what to call it one time shaggy
snapped his finger and Michelle just
disappeared she came back like 30
seconds later the shaggy meme is fun a
lot but the origin [ __ ] sucks like
this is all they took for a shaggy meme
to take off so bad so unfunny I'm sorry
it takes down the points from the shaggy
memes I was gonna rate it as sex now
it's time to it 3 next me now I know
what you're wondering
damn shaggy sure had a powerful level of
power Ness I know I feel the exact same
way who could possibly defeat shaggy is
there any way
Matt Matt from Wii Sports Matt from weed
sports as the
powerful three
just look at that cure pure body human
strength god damn my body is shivering
just looking at him like your reign of
terror ends now Matt dude I don't think
so if I had to place my bet I would say
Matt was gonna win it all the way son
you what ever wonder how Wakanda died it
was Matt now I know what you're thinking
it's our one man one man that can defeat
big chunga's Uganda knuckles and Shaggy
all together
there's one man and I think you know his
name that's right
is it me or is it getting very hot in
here because we're thinking of the same
one one man more Tungus than the big
chunky macho Martin
I am sorry my wedding cancelation I just
busted that her literal fat is not the
world has ever seen
his raspy voice guided my hands to
produce an almost inhuman quantity of
spirt my god moto moto my God motto
motto motto motto really speaks to me in
ways that no other man has ever touched
me before I didn't think I was a gay but
moto moto showed me that it was okay
Thank You moto moto you have changed my
perspective on life I don't think
there's a single human being that can
resist the charm and utter
of masculinity from moto moto moto moto
Co mate the Gillette commercials
instantly evaporated
[Music]
if you bug two vatos Oh moto moto comes
in many different shapes and colors and
forms motor motive be very attractive
you see what I'm talking about
moto moto can take any shape and
therefore he can take a shape with
shaggy and and will be shaggy they can
shape kill shaggy is shaggy
therefore moto moto most powerful being
in the planet
checkmate live girls damn it I'm sick of
this do you mean who is it gonna be us
alright this is definitely not old by
now what else do we got
no please stop just freakin stop motto
motto
what is so sexy multiple to is what now
I know everyone's been asking hate when
Zeeland you know much would you bonus me
but first we must spin the wheel of
boners meme okay axe axe ah I guess we
will check the next millenia if he can
appear on bonus me oh well we don't have
time for bonus me but we do have time
for pity mean Gillette commercial
everyone's favorite commercial of all
time if there was one good thing that
came out of it it's the memes at least
those I can appreciate bloodthirsty
vampire me sleeping the Domino's cheesy
garlic bread I ate earlier when I was
high t-series fede pie mr. beast with
Super Bowl ad damn I can't wait we got a
hold on a bit longer broski's and sis
keys keep subscribing if t series passes
before then every effort will be wasting
me eating poop nothing this is the kind
of game I can finally relate to I should
talk to more girls literally anyone me
me pity pie the N word Brides editing ok
stop
what's that another pity meme my joke
kid who repeated it but louder people
with missing limbs or other handicapped
fat people body accept hey guys that's
uncalled for man single dads Singam
spaceship Tesla colonizing Mars me oh
yeah he's never coming on okay hope you
guys enjoy this episode of meme review
if you enjoyed this episode of me where
you smash like and don't just click away
the video while you notice I'm doing the
outro I'm sick of people just clicking
away because I'm they notice the video
is over I actually have an important
message you want pyramids we got them oh
you're into castles huh we got you
covered baby you want some bets easy we
got it all this game is still relevant
goddammit
[Music]